growing up
in a working-class town in upstate new
york
i was taught to hope for a future with a
husband and two kids how about you
i saw women in my community marry
as a path to economic security
but often
end up with discontent
and even abuse instead
as i got older
i came to wonder
and i ask you now
what is family
what do we want family to be
the nuclear family has been the basis
for our cultural stories and our laws
but
only about half of u.s adults are
married
fewer every year
40 of us adults don't live with a
romantic partner at all
as of 2013
less than half of us children
had two married heterosexual parents in
their first marriage
the majority of us are not in a nuclear
family with a spouse and kids
yet somehow we treat this majority of
people
like social failures
what's worse
our laws treat unmarried people as
lesser citizens
marriage comes with over 1 000 rights
and benefits under federal law
these include the ability to get your
spouse citizenship share health
insurance get better tax rates and
inherit tax-free of death and more
part of the winning argument for
same-sex marriage was that we shouldn't
deprive
gay couples of all of these essential
benefits
but i ask you why should anyone be
denied benefits because they're in a
romantic relationship of which some
people disapprove
or because they're single
thank you
or because they're basing family on
something other than a romantic
relationship
like co-parenting a child
our laws should move away from the idea
that there's one ideal family form
and value all families as they exist
thank you
that's what i've dedicated my career to
and today
i'll share some of my visions for how we
can change u.s laws to benefit all
families but also how an expansive view
of family will strengthen all of your
own relationships
for nearly 15 years with my law firm for
lgbtq and non-nuclear families i've
supported same-sex couples
but also the many family forms beyond
marriage
like platonic partners
who are raising a child together or
sharing finances without a romantic
relationship
or grandparents who are raising their
grandchildren
or a lesbian couple co-parenting with a
male friend
or polyamorous partners who might be in
a committed relationship of three or
four
within that legal advocacy
i facilitate discussions to make sure
that everyone's intentions are aligned
and then help them design their own
family agreements
with the non-profit organization i
founded chosen family law center
i advocate for changes in u.s laws to
benefit this whole beautiful spectrum of
family constellations
and it is my core belief that no matter
how you form family
actively discussing how we intend to
live together is the best thing we can
do to strengthen our own personal
relationships
so how did we end up with this current
u.s emphasis on nuclear family
most of us throughout history have lived
in large extended family networks and 38
of the world population does today
the nuclear family is actually a
relatively new development
it emerged in the industrial revolution
to support a working dad and a homemaker
mom
it peaked in the 1950s and 60s but it
hasn't been the most common family forum
before or since
still somehow it's the basis for our
health insurance system how well is that
working out
and a reason for our lack of affordable
child care in this country
we still build and zone suburban homes
with this fictional family in mind
in western europe where i live and in
many other countries
states provide support for citizens in
need including parents who are home with
young children
such as paid maternity leave and
financial support throughout the
childhood if needed
but in u.s law
we make sure that financial safety net
happens between spouses
rather than between citizen and state
u.s marriage is a social welfare state
of two
i'd rather a different social welfare
state personally
this leaves many people especially women
stuck in unhealthy relationships
so
at this point
we can evaluate how same-sex partnership
when we move into that movement for
same-sex marriage
there was really an emphasis on whether
we should be pushing for gay marriage so
that gay people could get the benefits
of marriage or whether we should be
working to protect the rights of the
unmarried
and we can do both it's time now to
protect the rights of unmarried people
and other kinds of family constellations
thank you
[Music]
because the reality is there's no
evidence that the nuclear family model
is actually the best one
research has consistently shown that
children need stability of parental
figures
but from what i've consistently found it
doesn't matter if that stability is mom
and dad
two dads mom and grandma or three
polyamorous partners
so this is not only about justice
this is about what's best for children
if we really want that stability for
kids
we need to provide support for all the
kinds of families that kids are in
rather than try and fail to push people
into a nuclear family model with
government benefits
it's time to observe what's not working
and change course
my definition of family is people who
are committed to be there for each other
no matter what
this includes chosen family regardless
of biological relationship or legal
marriage
many black families in the u.s have
chosen aunties and uncles with no blood
relation but a decision to be family and
a commitment to the children involved
countless lgbtq people
create chosen family when they're
rejected by their family of origin or
when wanting to create families that
share their values
i am one of those queer people to find
home with chosen family
i grew up in a christian family in a
small town
the only child of wonderful older
parents
when i came out as bisexual
then as polyamorous then as gender
non-binary
most of my blood relations and over 30
cousins stopped talking to me
that's pretty standard
when i was a broke 20 something starting
my law practice i was diagnosed with
cervical cancer
and realized that i had been duped into
buying a health insurance that didn't
cover cancer
i was in a desperate life threatening
situation
and while my parents were loving they
couldn't provide me with material
support or problem solving
so i broke through my shame and my
embarrassment about asking for help
and i reached out to my communities of
friends
and i discovered that they were eager to
more actively support one another
they made a schedule so there was always
someone there to cook to clean to make
phone calls about my health coverage or
just sit with me while i cried in my
grief and my fear
when i won my appeal to receive coverage
by the cancer services medicaid program
the administrator called and said i
don't know who you are but a lot of
people love you
[Music]
and then she said and i'd like them to
stop calling my office now please
let them know you got coverage it's done
thank you
the chosen family who stepped up for me
probably saved my life
but they wouldn't necessarily be able to
visit me in the hospital
or cross a border in a pandemic to be
with me
because relationships beyond blood and
beyond marriage often don't get those
rights and since then my life's work has
been to change that and i will
when we embrace the idea of chosen
family our own free will is more
important than biological connection
we can choose to create family
relationships with the people who
provide us with the meaningful support
that we need and deserve
same-sex parenting has also advanced the
concept of family beyond biology because
in a same-sex couple only one parent's
providing the sperm or the egg
in my family building legal work with
these families i facilitate discussions
to make sure that everyone's intentions
are aligned before designing that legal
agreement
for example
i'll often work with a same-sex female
same-sex couple
who has a male friend who wants to help
them become parents so i'll facilitate
discussions to make sure they're all
clear on whether he's going to be a
co-parent or a sperm donor and design a
legal agreement either way
without that i've seen too many
situations of ambiguity
where mom calls him a dad when she needs
child care help
but a donor when it comes time to make a
big decision she doesn't want his input
on
he calls himself dad when the baby's
adorable at the park but feels more like
a donor when the school bill comes you
know
when we're designing our own families
we need clear written agreements
especially if children are involved
let's say i have two clients sharon and
bill
best friends were considering becoming
co-parents
sharon's turned 40 and hasn't found the
right man with whom to marry and have
kids
neither has her gay bestie bill who
can't afford the 100 000 surrogacy
process by himself
so they call each other their plan b
i would facilitate discussions with them
about their parenting values their plans
to share finances for the child their
ideal week of child care split
but the conversation often gets more
difficult when i ask questions like are
you willing to live in the same city for
the next 18 years to each be near the
child
we're used to the idea of sacrificing
for a spouse
and saying no to a dream job in a
different city to stay close to each
other
but it's a shocking idea to do that for
your buddy
but by becoming co-parenting partners
they need to elevate their level of
commitment from friends to platonic
partners
they need to consciously say goodbye to
a prince charming fantasy
and welcome and embrace a new reality of
a beautiful partnership grounded in
their long-term friendship
and agree that this co-parenting
relationship will come first
i have found in my work that these kinds
of discussions
are much more powerful for preventing
future disputes than any written
contract can be
we need to have these conversations
legal contracts are sometimes written to
avoid looking eye to eye and coming to
agreement
but family contracts should only be
written after you've done that
when i design relationships for
polyamorous triads of three or quads of
four
i sometimes use existing legal
structures like trusts or llcs
that allow you to share property and
finances without a question as to your
relationship
so for example if i've got a polyamorous
triad aisha susan and linda i can set up
an llc for them
so that they can co-own real estate
properties pay taxes together purchase a
common health insurance and have clear
exit strategies if they wish
thank you
[Music]
and if people trust each other enough to
pool their financial fortune and want to
pay taxes together
it shouldn't matter whether they're
business partners siblings or romantic
partners all of those families are valid
thank you
we should be able to choose legal
partners
beyond a single romantic partner like a
spouse
some people are doing that now and it's
the trends for the future
domestic partnerships have been used for
30 years by same-sex couples but also by
best friends and siblings
doing so as fasting partners allows you
to
share your health insurance
to visit each other in the hospital and
across borders in a pandemic
like spouses but unlike spouses you
don't become a social welfare state of
two which can be a good thing
i had a client who had a severely
disabled sister
by becoming domestic partners she was
able to put her sister on her excellent
health insurance coverage
why would a sister be any less worthy of
that than a boyfriend
right
thank you
we've built on that history
in 2020 my organization helped pass the
first
laws for multi-partner domestic
partnership which have passed in several
cities and counting
this means
that three or four polyamorous partners
could become domestic partners or two or
more platonic co-parents or any two
three or four people who want to become
each other's legal partners when
relationships have legal status like
this it reduces discrimination and
promotes social acceptance and awareness
as we saw in the same-sex partnership
movement
still we hope this year to pass the
first family status non-discrimination
laws at city levels across the united
states which means that you can't be
discriminated against you can't be fired
from your job or denied housing because
of your family configuration
in future i propose that we move from
these city-level domestic partnerships
to state-level multi-partner domestic
partnerships and then federal
recognition as we did with same-sex
marriage
and if we really want to value families
as they exist rather than incentivize
marriage i also suggest that we separate
out some of the legal perks of marriage
so that single people and other kinds of
families get these benefits without an
evaluation of whether they're in a
romantic relationship that passes muster
and
marriage should not be the gateway to
social and economic privilege anymore
that time is done
and marriages will be stronger when we
do that
do you know anyone who got married
faster than they should have for health
insurance or citizenship
because i know too many and i'm a
divorce lawyer
as a divorce lawyer relationships last
longer
when we marry for better reasons than
government perks
so many of you
may be married and may not think that
these issues have personal relevance for
you
but i ask you to reflect could your
relationship be stronger
if you adopted a more expansive view of
family
marriage and partnership are not one
size fits all
every couple in partnership benefits
from actively deciding how they want to
co-create together in terms of
co-parenting shared finances your
household and your definition of
monogamy
for example
is there any hidden expectation that you
have of your partner that would benefit
from being spoken out loud and confirmed
i bet there is
or is there any aspect of partnership
that you participate in just because
everyone does it like sleeping in the
same bed or only vacationing together
that just isn't really working for your
partnership
when we expect any one relationship in
our lives to meet most of our needs
we may be putting too much pressure on
that relationship
and whether it's your romantic partner
your parent your adult child your
relationship may be stronger if you also
strengthen other connections in your
lives and find other ways to get some of
your own needs
met my husband does not want to help me
process
i have other people for that in my life
so
i think it's worthwhile to question no
matter what kind of family configuration
you're in
whether you could be part of a movement
for greater interconnectedness
beyond our romantic relationships and
beyond the walls of our home
your family and your community will be
stronger when you do
is there a long-term friend that you
could reach out to
with whom you'd like to be better in
touch
and suggest a regular date for special
time together
could you create a child care
cooperative with other parents in your
community
is there a single parent or elderly
person in your life whose home you could
spend more time in
at some point in a long life
you too will need support
and it benefits you to practice asking
for support now
and actively caring for people in
community who may one day care for you
a baby whose diaper you change
may one day change yours
sorry
it's the beautiful reciprocity of human
relationship
and in my vision for the future while we
work together to redefine family in law
we can all redefine family in our own
culture and lives
there may even be a close friend to whom
you get the courage to ask
do you want to make family with me
thank you